Trascrizione: Cecilia Secco
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Non mi è mai piaciuto volare.
E so per certo di non essere l'unico:
circa sei persone su dieci
provano una sensazione
che va da un leggero disagio
a un profondo terrore,
quando devono prendere un volo aereo.
Non mi è mai piaciuto volare;
ed è un problema perché, al contrario,
amo profondamente viaggiare.
Viaggiare è stato un desiderio fortissimo
per me, nel corso della mia vita.
Anche solo la prospettiva
di poter partire
per andare a esplorare nuovi orizzonti,
nuove culture, nuovi sapori, nuove persone
è sempre stato qualcosa
che mi entusiasmava,
che mi rendeva felice.
Nonostante questa
passione viscerale per il viaggio,
che mi ha portato a fare di tutto
per poter lavorare viaggiando,
e quindi poter viaggiare il più possibile,
non ho mai amato volare.
Anzi, sono una di quelle persone
che quando si trovava
su un volo aereo un po' problematico,
con una turbolenza, si terrorizzava.
Ed era questo, più o meno, il pensiero
che avevo in mente alcuni anni fa
su un volo che da Hong Kong
mi stava riportando a Bali,
che è il posto che io chiamo casa
per alcuni mesi dell'anno.
Il volo stava andando alla perfezione,
quando, a un certo punto, la prima scossa,
quella sensazione
che tutti noi conosciamo.
Si accendono le luci del segnale
della cintura allacciata,
il comandante ordina a tutti di tornare
immediatamente al proprio posto
perché siamo appena entrati
in una fase con forti turbolenze.
Io non ero seduto, ovviamente,
ero sul fondo dell'aereo,
ero andato a chiedere un bicchiere d'acqua
quando tutto si mise a tremare
e il mio istinto fu quello di girarmi
e di andare immediatamente al mio posto,
ma mentre stavo per fare questo movimento,
qualcosa catturò la mia attenzione:
c'era un'hostess sul fondo dell'aereo
che sistemava gli snack sul carrello
e sembrava
la persona più tranquilla del mondo,
totalmente in pace con se stessa,
completamente disinteressata
a quella turbolenza
che invece stava terrorizzando me
e la maggior parte dei passeggeri.
Per me era inconcepibile,
non riuscivo a spiegarmi
come riuscisse a essere
così calma e tranquilla,
a continuare il suo lavoro
come se nulla fosse.
Così, approfittando di un momento
in cui l'aereo
non vibrava particolarmente,
decisi di andare a chiederglielo.
Mi lanciai, mi avvicinai, feci un sorriso
per celare il disagio e l'imbarazzo
e le chiesi semplicemente:
"Come fai a non avere paura?"
E vedete, il bello di viaggiare
è che ci sono dei momenti
apparentemente insignificanti
per gli altri,
che invece hanno la potenzialità
di cambiarti la vita.
E quello fu uno di quei momenti,
perché l'hostess si girò,
mi studiò per un attimo
un po' confusa per quella domanda
sicuramente inaspettata,
però poi mi rispose senza esitazioni
e mi disse:
"Gli aeroplani sono fatti per volare".
Quelle parole, nella loro semplicità,
iniziarono a risuonare dentro di me,
andarono a toccare
delle corde che avevo dentro
che neanche sapevo di avere.
Lei mi vide un po' confuso
e riprese a parlare.
Mi disse: "Lo sai
che ci sono molte più possibilità
che un aeroplano causi un incidente
quando è per terra,
rispetto a quando è in volo?
Perché gli aeroplani sono dei mezzi
estremamente pesanti, sono ingombranti,
sono difficili da manovrare per terra.
Gli aeroplani sono stati progettati
e studiati per stare in cielo.
Il cielo, è la loro dimensione:
quando un aeroplano è in cielo
non hai nulla di cui preoccuparti.
Gli aeroplani sono fatti per volare."
E con quell'ultima frase fece un sorriso,
mi indicò il segnale delle cinture
e mi congedò.
Io tornai subito al mio posto
e avevo tutte queste parole
che mi risuonavano dentro.
Decisi di fare una cosa
che non avevo mai fatto:
guardai fuori dal finestrino.
Non l'avevo mai fatto, perché pensavo
che rendermi conto
dell'altezza a cui viaggiavo
e della velocità a cui andava l'aereo
mi avrebbe terrorizzato.
Guardai fuori e non vidi niente:
non c'era niente perché era notte fonda,
quindi vedevo a malapena l'ala dell'aereo.
Eppure non avevo nessuna paura,
mi sentivo tranquillo
e, per assurdo, mi sentivo
per la prima volta nella mia vita
al sicuro su un aereo.
Da quel giorno, non ho mai più avuto
paura di volare,
ma non è questa la cosa più importante
che è successa a bordo di quel volo aereo,
perché quelle semplici parole,
semplici ma in un certo senso illuminanti,
di quell'hostess, quella strana
conversazione che ho avuto con lei
aveva dato il via a un effetto domino
di riflessioni
che mi portarono a una riflessione finale:
gli aeroplani sono fatti per volare,
su questo non c'è dubbio,
e noi esseri umani, invece,
per cosa siamo fatti?
Qual è la nostra dimensione,
come il cielo lo è per l'aeroplano?
Che cosa possiamo fare ogni singolo giorno
per poter essere felici?
Per sentirci realizzati?
Io ho cercato a lungo una risposta,
mi è rimasta proprio dentro
questa serie di domande,
e l'ho cercata fuori la risposta.
L'ho cercata confrontandomi
con altre culture,
con altri modi di intendere la vita,
leggendo tanti libri,
guardando tanti film.
Poi un giorno mi sono reso conto che
la risposta ce l'avevo dentro.
Dovevo semplicemente riavvolgere il nastro
e andare a rivedere tutte le esperienze
che avevo vissuto in giro per il mondo,
tutti gli stati d'animo che avevo avuto.
Ero sicuro che facendo questo processo
avrei trovato la risposta.
Così partii da quando ero un ragazzo
appena uscito dal liceo,
convinto che la forma della sua felicità
fosse quella più tradizionale,
quella che gli era stata insegnata
fin da piccolo quindi:
laureati, prendi magari
una seconda laurea,
trova un bel lavoro prestigioso,
inizia a lavorare duramente
per poi poterti permettere una casa,
magari una casa in centro
da ostentare agli amici
e avere un'automobile potente
con cui girare la domenica mattina
per farti vedere dagli altri
e suscitare un po' di invidia.
Credevo fosse quella
la forma della mia felicità.
Così avevo iniziato questo percorso,
mi ero iscritto all'università
pensando di fare il primo passo
in quella direzione.
Poi però mi resi conto dopo pochi mesi
che non sarei riuscito
a trovare la felicità in quel modo,
perché anche solo pensare a quella vita
mi rendeva infelice.
Non perché sia sbagliato,
ma per me non poteva funzionare,
la forma della mia felicità
non poteva essere quella.
Così decisi a vent'anni
di lasciare l'università,
prendere tutti i risparmi che avevo
e comprare un biglietto di sola andata
per l'Australia,
con l'intenzione di arrivare là,
cercare lavoro per poter sopravvivere,
ma soprattutto
esplorare gli stili di vita alternativi,
le alternative, cercare delle risposte.
E così iniziò il mio girare per il mondo
che adesso dura da più di otto anni,
ma quello che è stato veramente importante
del mio girovagare,
sono stati gli incontri che ho fatto.
In Australia, ad esempio,
conobbi un ragazzo italiano
che si era trasferito lì
alcuni anni prima
e faceva l'istruttore di surf.
Lui si alzava ogni mattina all'alba,
prendeva la sua tavola, percorreva a piedi
le poche centinaia di metri
che lo separavano dall'oceano,
si buttava nel mare con un entusiasmo
che non avevo mai visto nella mia vita,
e quando era tra le onde,
era la persona più felice del mondo.
Ecco, se a lui avessero chiesto:
"Per cosa sei fatto?",
lui avrebbe risposto senza esitazioni:
"Sono fatto per fare surf".
Se poteva svegliarsi ogni mattina
e fare surf era felice,
indipendentemente da ciò che accadeva
nel resto della sua giornata.
Qualche anno più tardi,
mi trasferii in Canada e lì conobbi
un personaggio veramente curioso:
un uomo di 70 anni
che aveva lavorato per trent'anni
in una grossa banca canadese,
anche con un impiego
di una certa responsabilità e prestigio.
Poi un giorno si era stufato,
infelice di quella vita,
e aveva deciso di licenziarsi,
prendere la liquidazione,
e investirla per fare il giro del mondo.
E così aveva fatto:
aveva iniziato a girare tutto il mondo,
visitando decine di paesi, immergendosi
in tantissimi modi di vivere diversi,
tantissime culture diverse.
E aveva capito, alla fine,
che non c'era nessun posto
migliore di quello che lui da sempre
chiamava casa.
Vancouver, era il posto più bello
del mondo per lui.
Allora era tornato a Vancouver,
ma questa volta
non più per lavorare in banca,
ma per fare ciò che lo rendeva felice.
Aveva comprato un terreno
e aveva iniziato a coltivare mirtilli.
Quando lui mi raccontò questo fatto,
io rimasi un attimo confuso, gli dissi:
"I mirtilli? E perché i mirtilli dopo
tutto quello che hai fatto,
i viaggi, la banca...".
E lui mi rispose semplicemente:
"Per me i mirtilli sono la felicità.
Poterli coltivare, poterli prendere,
poterne fare delle marmellate,
dei biscotti, e il mio risotto
che è il più buono di tutto il Canada -
sottolineava sempre - mi rende felice".
Più recentemente, un paio di anni fa,
ho incontrato una ragazza a Bali,
che mi ha raccontato la sua storia,
anche lei si era trasferita a vivere lì.
La sua storia era veramente particolare:
era arrivata sull'isola,
come tanti altri turisti, per visitarla.
Una volta lì, però, si era innamorata
di quel luogo e un giorno,
mentre guidava il suo scooter,
si rese conto di quanti cani randagi
ci fossero in giro.
Questa consapevolezza
la colpì con tale forza
che lei decise di rimanere a Bali,
ma per prendersi cura dei cani randagi.
Così iniziò a lavorare come volontaria
in un ambulatorio, poi ne aprì uno suo
e adesso questa è la sua vita.
Una vita estremamente più dura,
difficile, sporca
rispetto a quella che aveva,
molto più semplice, in occidente,
ma una vita piena,
una vita che la rende felice.
E se trovi la tua felicità, in fondo,
non hai bisogno di nient'altro.
Ecco, io ne ho conosciute
a decine di persone così,
con una forma della loro felicità
veramente alternativa e strana.
E ripensando a loro, mi sono reso conto
che non possiamo rispondere alla domanda:
"per cosa siamo fatti?",
perché noi esseri umani
siamo molto più complicati
di un aeroplano.
Se tu chiedi a una persona:
"che forma ha la tua felicità?",
ogni singola persona ti dà
una risposta diversa, oppure,
ancora più grave, ti risponde "non lo so".
Quindi la vera domanda non è questa.
Perché c'è un comune denominatore
tra tutte le persone felici
che ho incontrato, ed è il fatto
che erano tutte riuscite
a valorizzare il loro tempo.
Avete presente quella sensazione,
che sono sicuro molti di voi
hanno provato almeno una volta nella vita,
di arrivare sul posto di lavoro,
guardare l'orologio,
vedere che sono le 9 e un quarto e dire:
"Dannazione, cosa non darei per poter
far volare le prossime otto ore,
per poterle consumare
e teletrasportarmi a stasera,
quando sarò libero
di fare quello che voglio".
Io questa sensazione
la provavo all'università,
era davvero una situazione
che non mi rendeva felice.
Mi sentivo come un animale in gabbia,
quindi arrivavo in aula e dicevo:
"Quanto vorrei consumare in fretta
queste ore".
Ecco, nessuna delle persone felici
che ho incontrato sul mio percorso
aveva questi pensieri,
ma a dire la verità nessuno di loro
neanche si chiedeva che cos'è la felicità.
Lo erano perché
erano riusciti a riempire il loro tempo
di ciò che gli piace fare.
Allora alla domanda:
"Cosa possiamo fare ogni singolo giorno
per valorizzare il nostro tempo?",
ho trovato delle risposte in questo caso.
Ho ripensato al mio percorso,
e queste sono le tre fasi
per valorizzare il proprio tempo,
quelle che funzionano per me,
ma potrebbero benissimo
funzionare anche per voi.
La prima fase è:
trovare il proprio "Ikigai".
Ikigai è un termine giapponese
che significa ragion d'essere.
È lo scopo della vita di una persona,
è il motivo per cui al mattino
ti alzi e vivi.
La maggior parte delle persone
non sa rispondere a:
"qual è il tuo ikigai?".
Chi invece riesce a rispondere
non solo ha valorizzato il proprio tempo,
ma probabilmente
ha anche trovato la felicità.
Perché secondo i giapponesi,
l'ikigai è l'intersezione
di quattro aspetti:
ciò che ami fare, ciò che sai fare,
ciò che puoi condividere con gli altri
magari per fare del bene,
e ciò che puoi fare per mantenerti,
per pagare le bollette,
per poterti mantenere per l'appunto.
Il punto più importante è forse l'ultimo,
riuscire a fare dell'ikigai un lavoro,
perché io stesso desideravo che il tempo
passasse in fretta,
ma dal momento in cui sono riuscito a fare
della passione per la scrittura un lavoro,
del viaggio, un'altra mia passione,
uno stile di vita, e da quando ho iniziato
ad avere degli obiettivi in cui credo,
ho smesso di desiderare
che il tempo passi in fretta.
Mi sveglio e vorrei
che le giornate passassero lente,
vorrei non sprecarne neanche una.
Trovare il proprio ikigai è fondamentale
per valorizzare il proprio tempo.
E come si trova l'ikigai?
Credo che ci siano tanti modi,
ma uno dei più efficaci
è tornare indietro con la mente
a quando si era giovani,
a quando si era un adolescente.
Che adulto sognavi di diventare?
Quali erano i tuoi sogni?
E non è importante se non sei riuscito
a diventare il chitarrista di una band
famosa in tutto il mondo,
perché da giovane
sei anche un po' infantile ovviamente.
Ma se la musica
era la tua più grande passione,
era ciò che più ti accendeva, e sei finito
a digitare cifre davanti a un computer
per otto ore al giorno
rinchiuso dentro quattro pareti,
allora qualcosa è andato storto.
Se il tuo sogno era di diventare
una veterinaria,
occuparti ogni giorno degli animali,
e ti sei laureata in giurisprudenza
per far contenta tua madre,
qualcosa è andato storto.
Queste situazioni non solo creano
una grande insoddisfazione,
ma anche un sentimento di odio,
di invidia,
perché non fai quello che ti piace
e sai che c'è qualcuno là fuori
che lo sta facendo,
o perché ha avuto più coraggio
o più fortuna, ma comunque
c'è qualcuno là fuori che lo sta facendo,
e questo a lungo andare, ti logora,
ti rovina la vita.
La seconda fase
per valorizzare il proprio tempo,
è essere viaggiatori.
Significa ovviamente viaggiare nel mondo,
è un consiglio che do a chiunque.
Investire i propri soldi nei viaggi,
significa dar valore al proprio tempo,
aggiungere vita alla vita.
D'altronde capita spesso di passare
intere settimane a casa,
di cui non si ha nessun ricordo,
poi parti per un viaggio,
e di ogni singola giornata ricordi tutto,
hai vari ricordi.
Questa credo sia
una delle definizioni più belle
del valorizzare il proprio tempo:
ricordare.
Se non la ricordi non puoi dire
di aver vissuto la vita fino in fondo;
ma il vero senso dell'essere viaggiatori
non è collezionare timbri sul passaporto,
è una questione di mentalità.
Qual è il contrario di viaggiare?
Il contrario è stare fermi.
Stare fermi fisicamente,
ma anche fermi sulle proprie posizioni,
rinchiudersi nelle abitudini,
in ciò che conosciamo, non rischiare,
non andare mai a esplorare l'ignoto.
E allora essere viaggiatori
è una questione di stile di vita,
di approccio alla vita.
Faccio un esempio: se ogni mattina
vedi una ragazza che magari ti piace,
la osservi però poi non riesci mai
a fare quel passo per andare a parlarle,
buttati, parti, viaggia dentro di lei,
dentro i suoi sogni,
nel suo modo di vedere la vita,
nel suo passato, nei suoi progetti,
nelle sue ambizioni, buttati!
Questo vuol dire essere viaggiatori.
Hai un brutto rapporto con tuo padre
e non ne parlate mai,
avete quel muro di indifferenza
tra di voi?
Iniziate un viaggio insieme,
fate quella conversazione
che rimandate da troppi anni.
Questo significa essere viaggiatori.
Vuol dire smettere di essere passeggeri,
e diventare piloti della propria vita,
prenderne il controllo,
questo significa essere viaggiatori.
E il terzo punto per imparare
a valorizzare il proprio tempo,
e quello che forse mi sta
un po' più a cuore,
è essere artigiani del proprio tempo.
Nel corso del mio girare per il mondo
ho svolto decine di lavori diversi,
tra cui quello del panificatore.
Mi svegliavo ogni notte, quando
tutti dormivano, e iniziavo a lavorare,
e poi andavo a dormire
mentre tutti erano al lavoro.
È una vita molto dura,
una vita non semplice,
però il lavoro del panificatore,
dà la grande possibilità di pensare,
di riflettere, tu sei lì che impasti,
intanto con la mente ragioni, rifletti,
e fai delle scoperte che ti possono
cambiare la vita.
In quel periodo io ne feci una, e cioè
che il mio pane, quello che facevo per me,
era il più buono del mondo,
e attenzione non perché io sia
il miglior panificatore del mondo,
ma perché era mio.
Lo avevo scelto io quel pane,
lo avevo modellato come volevo io,
gli avevo messo gli ingredienti
che più mi piacevano,
lo avevo cotto come piaceva a me,
gli avevo dato la forma che volevo io.
Era fatto esattamente sulla forma
del mio gusto.
E credo che questa sia un'ottima metafora
di ciò che significa
valorizzare il proprio tempo.
Il tempo lo dovete modellare,
dovete essere artigiani del vostro tempo,
non dei consumatori,
non potete trovarlo preconfezionato
sullo scaffale del supermercato
come avviene invece con il pane.
Il vostro tempo lo dovreste modellare
sulla forma della vostra felicità,
qualunque essa sia.
Questo è fondamentale.
E per riuscire a essere artigiani
del proprio tempo,
c'è un modo che mi ha trasmesso
un monaco buddista.
Alcuni anni fa, ho avuto l'onore
e il privilegio di parlare
con un anziano monaco buddista
a Chiang Mai in Thailandia,
al quale posi una domanda provocatoria,
gli chiesi:
"C'è un modo per essere felici
ogni singolo giorno?"
Lui mi disse: "La felicità, per
come la intendete voi occidentali,
è una questione di imparare a vivere
nel momento presente,
perché voi occidentali siete ossessionati
dal passato e dal futuro,
ma il passato non torna, e quindi
non ha alcun effetto su di voi,
quindi non esiste il passato.
Il futuro non è altro che un'ipotesi:
voi state ipotizzando di averlo un futuro
ma non è detto,
quindi non dovreste neanche pensarci,
dovreste vivere ogni singola giornata
come fosse un nuovo inizio,
come se fosse una nuova vita,
e se ci riuscite,
riuscite a darvi la possibilità
di essere felici ogni singolo giorno,
perché ogni giorno è un nuovo inizio,
si parte tutto da capo".
Io ho cercato di fare mia
questa filosofia di vita,
e la prima cosa che ho fatto è stata
smettere di essere schiavo del calendario.
È una cosa a cui ho pensato
soltanto negli ultimi anni
e mi sono reso conto di quanto
siamo schiavi delle date sul calendario.
C'è una data che ci dice quando possiamo
essere felici,
c'è una data che invece rappresenta
un giorno qualsiasi, anonimo,
che non vale niente.
C'è una data in cui
dobbiamo essere tristi,
perché torniamo dalle ferie
e si torna a lavorare.
Il punto è che, riuscire a capire che
ogni singola giornata è un nuovo inizio,
è davvero un passo importantissimo
verso la propria felicità.
Perché, la vedete questa foto?
Io non l'ho scattata il giorno di Natale,
non l'ho scattata
il giorno del mio compleanno,
non era sabato sera, quel momento
in cui ti senti costretto a essere felice.
Non so nemmeno quando è stata scattata
questa foto.
Però ricordo che ero
su un'isola thailandese, Koh Lipe,
e ricordo che questa giornata è stata
una delle più felici della mia vita.
Questa è l'unica cosa che conta.
Pertanto, l'augurio che faccio a chiunque
incontro sulla mia strada
è quello che c'è scritto
sul mio taccuino di viaggio:
"have a nice life".
Trovate il vostro ikigai,
siate viaggiatori della vita,
siate artigiani del vostro tempo,
e riuscirete a ottenere
esattamente questo: una buona vita.
Grazie.
[Applausi]